I spoke to President Erdogan for an hour
today Turkey does of course have
justified security interest but I
believe as does the federal government
that the offensive must be stopped in
view of the grave humanitarian
consequences dwu reporter William no
igloo Croft Joey now in studio and
William has more on this now look
Chancellor Merkel is known to be
cautious when it comes to getting
involved in any sort of international
conflicts what do you make of this phone
call cautious is to put it mildly
I mean Angela Merkel has been in power
for almost 15 years there's almost no
examples of her taking a leading or
proactive role especially when it comes
to foreign policy especially it comes to
military policy not only Angela Merkel
but Germany as a country does not tell
other countries what to do given its
history of occupying other countries and
yet this phone call and yet this phone
call so this is incredible and on top of
that the threat the Germany faces of
from Turkey of the refugees that turkey
is keeping there as part of an EU turkey
deal and that Angela Merkel still makes
this phone call despite the risks the
political and just PR risks of how it
looks is is really can't be understated
and we should mention apparently this
phone call was requested by air Dewan
himself but but miracles saying these
things on that phone call now before
that phone call Germany and other
countries had also announced that they
would halt and weapons exports to Turkey
here's how President Juan responded
today
take a listen despite the fact that
we've been saying this for months there
are those who threaten us with economic
sanctions and arms embargoes those who
think they will turn Turkey away from
its path have been mistaken and are
mistaken well William the Netherlands
France Norway Germany and others they've
they've also announced an end to weapons
exports to Turkey yet all of those
countries interestingly their NATO
allies I mean they're supposed to be
working together right NATO allies but
also EU members Sweden a NATO partner
not a member but a NATO partner they've
also called for a common EU response
it's fascinating to see what's happening
now Turkey we cannot say this enough is
a NATO member
have the same rights the same
obligations as every other NATO country
and this has been a long brewing
conflict within NATO but what to do with
Turkey as turkey tilts ever more to
dictatorship to losing its democratic
institutions under air dhawan and NATO
prides itself in being an alliance of
democracies so we're seeing we're seeing
maybe for the first time a real hard
split within NATO itself and between
NATO and the EU let's talk about the EU
we're also hearing that the European
Union is preparing a common response to
Turkey do you think we're seeing Europe
stepping in now to fill the power vacuum
that's been left by the United States
you know the United States occupies such
a huge amount of power in the world
it'll be hard to see how even a block as
big as the European Union could really
step into that after decades of sort of
shirking its responsibilities on the
internationals on the world scale but we
see that's that's where we're going the
United States diffract threatening
saying yes but nothing yet Trump is
threatening but also the same time de
facto greenlit this operation by pulling
US troops out of harm's way to allow
Turkey to go in but let's not forget the
u.s. is the real power broker here it's
the US has provides most of the arms to
Turkey I mean 2,400 main battle tanks
Turkey has those are all from the US so
just how much power and influence EU
and/or European NATO members can have in
this situation really remains to be seen
it's gonna be fascinating to see how it
develops GW reporter William doe igloo
cough thank you very much